well Tad with the weather we've been
having lately Valley flood patterns are
changing in Las Vegas and that's why a
new study shows that's what a new study
shows us from the desert Research
Institute Mary Jane bellezza looking
into this live now at Eastern in di with
more on why and what that means for
those of us Mary Jane who live here
Denise and Brian this wash is just one
of the many flood channels across the
valley and you can see it stretches
hundreds of miles returning storm water
back to Lake Mead now that study shows
the shift of seasonal flooding and how
the city is adapting
in just the past several years the Las
Vegas population grew to over 2 million
with the growth comes the need for flood
channels and drainages and monitoring
our ever-changing weather patterns guayu
with the desert Research Institute is
studying how Urban Development and the
climate can alter flood risks and how we
can adapt the Clark County Regional
Flood Control District built a number of
storm drains to push water away from our
city and into Lake Mead
before that we can see more flooding
occurring like on because it's not the
Innovation across the city but after the
initiation of the flag control this real
lies lies in addition is unhappening
here in Las Vegas but but more water
appeared in the downstream the study
also looked at how floods now happen
more in the winter instead of the
historically Summer monsoon season
genvarian a meteorologist with the
National Weather Service says Winters
are a wet season we have the winter rain
which is about half of the rainfall that
we typically get in a season or in a
year and then the monsoon is about the
other half to three quarters so since
December 1st which is the start of
meteorological winter we've had .69 so
we have seen the winter class than the
summer class in most recent uh three
decades so that is related to the
climate change
the Clark County Regional flood control
is responsible for developing and
implementing flood control Master plans
for the county and individual flood
control plans must be reviewed every
five years reporting live Mary Jane
beliesza 8 news now Mary Jane thank you
now before the regional Flood Control
District was created the U.S soil
conservation service documented 184
distinct flood events in Clark County
those resulting in Damages to private as
well as public property